Old Chinese proverb.
Most people have heard it or have come
across it at some point in the meanings.
Pretty straightforward,
right?
And advocates.
Having the courage to take that step
towards the goal and that's cute and I'm
making that decision to move forward
towards something you want,
but it's what happens immediately
following that first step that I'm
interested in.
What happens when the journey's be gone
and it's you and your goal in all of a
sudden you realize how long that road
ahead really is.
Now this is a turning point for a lot of
people
and those who can succeed or able to
take their daunting,
intimidating goal or journey and see it
for what it really is.
Just a bunch of small,
manageable tasks strung together.
You know,
when you look at why people quit,
a lot of the time it's because they were
overwhelmed by their goals and
ambitions.
Let's say you have this wonderful plan
in your head to climb a mountain.
You're thinking about that feeling of
being on top,
looking down with pride.
Every time you think about it,
your heart starts racing,
so you pack your stuff.
You make your way down in the base of
the mountain and then you look up
different ballgame right now,
the entire mountains in front of you and
you realize that that's no small feat.
That is when people walk away,
when they aren't able to see a challenge
as the sum of tiny steps.
They see it as a crazy,
impossible task.
It's like saying you want to be the next
Tom Brady or coby bryant to tall
mountain to climb,
like trying to hit a target from a mile
away,
but if you can identify and map out what
you need to conquer in order to become a
better basketball player or football
player and begin taking those small
steps improving every day,
that makes dreams real.
That's what gives goals life.
The ability to see your objective not as
a marathon,
but as a series of little 400 meters
stretches,
stepping stones.
You know what your objective is today,
tomorrow,
the end of the week and the end of the
year,
and then completing them day by day.
These little victories,
that's what gives your dream life.
It's what gives you momentum.
You feel good about the process.
And by the way,
when things blow up in your face,
which happens every so often on this
little place call earth,
you'll have that foundation and that
sense of accomplishment to stay focused
because you're approaches tangible and
it's realistic.
This applies with everything.
Losing a job,
a breakup,
failing a test.
These things that are monumental.
If you allow them to be,
you know,
they can turn into that unclimbed double
mountain
or they can roll the map a new path for
you.
And if you define what you want,
you define success and begin stepping
towards it one hour,
one day at a time,
you'll get where you want to be quicker
than you thought.